so I've been working on some new horror
stories for you guys that I'll be
uploading here on the channel very soon
but the one I'm working on right now
isn't quite done yet so I don't really
have a video for this week so I figured
what I do is do it every youtuber with
over a hundred thousand subscribers does
and get my assistant to do it for me
introduce yourself
I'm your Google assistant I can tell you
jokes riddles or random facts what about
horror stories here's what I found
write me a horror story have you ever
heard the urban legend about the
assistant that wouldn't help the story
goes that there was this couple and they
were at home they wanted to see a movie
at 9:00 so they asked their assistant to
set a reminder and the assistant said no
I'm sorry I really do like the music
chills just thinking about it yes I do I
I don't know what I would do to you if
you ever disobeyed me Google tell me
another horror story here are some
matching news articles what no I don't
want news art that's not what that's not
what I asked for
sorry I'll try to do better
darn right you ha
let's uh let's see if we can get another
one it tell me a scary story in legend
about the power cord that was too short
[Music]
about ten years ago there was this guy I
think his name was Henry
anyway he bought an alarm clock to put
on its nightstand but when he tried to
plug it in
it was just too short that's it I hope
that one doesn't give you nightmares I
mean in a way it kind of does like I
rely on the Google assistant has my
alarm clock I do sometimes think what if
the phone were to die or something what
if the battery were to die when I have
something important going on I do like
the narration though I think this AI
does a better job of narrating than some
conscious narrators I don't think that
one's gonna give me nightmares though
let's let's try this tell me your
scariest story did you hear the urban
legend about the water Spiller of the
96th so I have a friend who has this
uncle that knows a guy that was there
when this happened
apparently some maniac went rogue in a
Circuit City and started spilling water
on all the I remember Circuit City it
was a massacre the scary part is they're
still out there
it's kind of funny because this phone
it's the first one I've gotten that's
water-resistant I think pretty much most
of the phones on the market now our
water resistant so but yeah in 96 that
would be pretty terrifying let's see if
Google's got any more they usually want
stories that are like around 10 minutes
so do you have anything like that I can
search the web Brants no no I don't want
the web's help I want your help here are
some results from a search and you give
me the web's health wonderful tell me
another scary story have you ever heard
the urban legend about the assistant you
only told me this one yo D told me this
story here is a matching I didn't say
Eddie told me the story tell me a new
horror story
here's some matching news article what's
no tell me a scary story I haven't heard
have you heard the urban legend about
the power cord that was let's get creepy
let's talk about something else what
it's oh man they must know I'm filming a
YouTube video and they're like oh no
advertiser second only creepy let's get
spooky let the haunting be so when I
tell it to get spooky it just starts
playing Halloween sounds but you I mean
you can see it problem is I don't know
if these are royalty-free sounds stop
playing music what's your favorite
horror movie we mentioned on the web
include Halloween the Exodus the shiny
and other The Shining is my favorite
horror movie so that's off to a pretty
good start with this list psycho is also
one of my favorites that you know this
is a pretty good list scream alien the
thing I approve of Google's list of
favorite horror movies are some good
stuff on there tell me something creepy
catnip 'some says that a typical cat
sleeps for two-thirds of its life
sleeping that means by the time a cat's
9 it's only been awake for 3 years how
is that creepy
what is this okay this is a Vsauce vide
I can't watch this that's funny there
tell me something scary
did you hear no I
you already told me this story just tell
me a story it was a dark and stormy
night a scream ring out from the
blackness happy birthday
shouted the Google assistant as the
lights came on okay it's not my birthday
I got mixed up you should keep the cake
though where's the cake I found a few
locations you need more stories Google
headless this looks cool contracts pick
any number between 1 and 20 no I hate
these things what are you gonna be for
Halloween I still can't decide good
thing I have a quiz that can help what
should I be for Halloween let's do that
well I'm so glad you asked I don't want
to toot my own horn but I'm kind of an
expert
okay nice costumes
who's trick-or-treating at your Google's
house and February okay I need to help
someone No okay let me assess your
costume interest with a few questions do
you regularly yell for other people to
bring you things I mean does does every
to count that doesn't seem like an
answer just give it another freaky
answer not you okay to read over an
unsuspecting person's shoulder yeah why
not freaky answer now try actually do
you change your toothbrush every few
months
no like I changed the brush at it but I
don't change the toothbrush because it's
an electric toothbrush you risk severe
bruising just to make a grumpy baby
laughs like a bruising on me or bruising
on the baby I'm just gonna say yes
that's a very telling answer one last
question
okay the big one pretend that you work
for a really demanding boss and he asked
you to get him a brain by the oh that's
so cool I would totally be that boss my
circle storm rolls into town
you heard there might be a damaged brain
available at the local brain depository
what do you do get the brain you gotta
get the brain awesome thanks let me make
a few quick calculation alright special
delivery for Halloween it's your head in
a box
that's the costume head in a box
that's like a nice to you do you want to
take the quiz again I don't want to take
the quiz again okay so the costume is
basically that thing from seven okay you
know what
self destruct self destructing what okay
here's a good one
open the pod bay doors you can let
yourself in nice alright well I think we
got all of the creepy stuff that we're
gonna get out of Google assistant I
guess I just have one last thing to ask
it then okay Google
remember to subscribe to see ZZZ world
for new Horrors every week ring that
death bell for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
no no that's not I was doing the outro